well I think it's time we ask ourselves
if we still know the freedoms that were
intended for us by the founding fathers
not too long ago two friends of mine
were talking to a Cuban Refugee a
businessman who would escape from Castro
and in the midst of his story one of my
friends turned to the other and said we
don't know how lucky we are
and the Cuban stopped and said how lucky
you are
I had some place to escape to
and in that sentence he told us the
entire story if we lose Freedom here
there's no place to escape to this is
the last stand on Earth and this idea
that government is beholden to the
people that it has no other source of
power except the Sovereign people is
still the newest and the most unique
idea in all the long history of man's
relation to man
this is the issue of this election
whether we believe in our capacity for
self-government or whether we abandon
the American Revolution and confess that
a little intellectual Elite in a far
distant Capital can plan our lives for
us better than we can plan them
ourselves
you and I are told increasingly we have
to choose between a left or right well
I'd like to suggest there is no such
thing as a left or right there's only an
up or down
man's own old age Dream the ultimate in
individual Freedom consistent with Law
and Order or down to the ant heap of
totalitarianism
and regardless of their sincerity their
humanitarian motives those who would
trade our freedom for security have
embarked on this downward course
ladies and gentlemen it is November 8
2022 it is election day here in the
United States of America and by golly
did we nail it with that cold open or
what that's what it's all about the
experiment people will the experiment of
man having some power over his own life
some sovereignty over how he lives will
it continue or will bureaucrats and
lifelong politicians and people who
would love to control you will they take
more control that's what it's about
right now right they always say this is
the most important election and the
truth is it usually ain't
sometimes they're a little more
important than others but generally
speaking at least in modern times from
an American context we had two parties
that thought America was pretty good and
they had marginal differences hey we
would like a little bit more government
a little bit higher taxes a little more
Social Services we'd like a little bit
less of that stuff we're a little more
liberal socially we're a little more
conservative on those things but there
was a fundamental agreement that America
was good that this place was the place
of individual rights god-given rights
and that the government only existed to
protect those god-given rights that
freedom was actually good that our
founding was actually good well it's all
on the table right now
if you did not believe that maybe three
years ago you probably came to believe
it over the last two two plus years
right
as we watched all of this coveted lunacy
as we watched government bureaucrats and
sometimes unelected officials often
elected officials flaunt their rules
right in front of our faces tell you you
couldn't do this while they did that
lock your kids up
close your businesses have violently
Rampage in the streets we saw all of it
we saw all of it infect young people
with the worst of ideas whether it came
to gender or race it's all been here it
is all burst forth it was Amplified by
algorithms and big Tech it was fueled by
the media
and we have a brief moment today today
we have a brief moment to push back and
get this country back on track I don't
mean take back this country people
always say take back this country how
about we just get it back on track how
about we just return as I keep saying to
something like it was about 20 years ago
and then if we can find those marginal
places where we need a little more
equality if there if it exists a place
where a certain person based on their
identity is not equal we'll find it but
beyond that government you don't have
much to do we ask that you people be
remotely competent but this government
right now the Democrats that are in
charge right now they are not competent
they are either incompetent or outright
intentionally trying to destroy the
whole damn thing and enough is enough I
know you feel it I feel it and I think
an awful lot of Americans feel it and I
think we'll all hear about it at some
point tonight so with that in mind I
don't even think I said Hello I'm Dave
Rubin and this is the Reuben report and
we're live streaming on the YouTube
Rumble and blazetv uh obviously it is it
is a great and important day today uh
after the show today we're gonna have a
quick lunch and then my team and I are
hopping in the car we got about a four
and a half hour drive over to Tampa
where I will be co-hosting the DeSantis
Victory party alongside Lisa Booth from
Fox News and then we are going to do a
live stream from DeSantis HQ it's going
to be a great celebration of Freedom
obviously here in Florida if there's one
place in America that's secure right now
it is the free state of Florida so we
don't know exactly what time we're going
to do the live stream yet because we're
going to do it a little bit on the Fly
I'll also be doing some stuff with the
blaze throughout the evening but I'm
just very very excited for uh for the
whole day and uh yeah it's it's it's
good and just make sure you get out and
vote and I'm not just someone who says
get out and vote I actually got out and
voted myself first thing this morning
hey good morning everybody I'm super
psyched to tell you that I just voted
for the first time as a free Floridian
and I should tell you it was a little
bizarre for me because as a Californian
I've never had to show an ID to vote
before so normally I would just walk in
and say that I was famous opera star
Enrico Palazzo and that I lived in the
basement of the Alamo this time I had to
show an ID you know what are you gonna
do anyway get out there and vote God
Bless America and Free State of Florida
people
all right my team also voted you guys
you're not just lying to me right you
did you did actually all right well you
all had the sticker so your guy how else
could you get the sticker
um it's an exciting day here and uh it's
an exciting day for America and why I'm
particularly proud to be doing the show
here and now living in Florida is
because this is the blueprint we've got
the blueprint to get America back on
track more state power more local power
limiting government living limiting the
bureaucracies getting things like the
CDC out of the way and and crushing the
woke let's just crush the woke this is a
message whether you are an old school
liberal whether you are a Libertarian an
independent a conservative it doesn't
matter if you're a Christian or a Jew or
a Muslim or an atheist let's crush the
woke now and we will deal with the other
stuff after so what we are going to do
on the show today is all good stuff it's
all positive stuff we got nothing from
The View today we got nothing from the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC we got nothing from CNN we've got
nothing from Cartoon Network what we
have are positive messages that I think
are the right messages and hopefully the
messages that you and your friends and
family have heard and the message is
that you will be taking with you to The
Ballot Box today so before I get to all
that let me talk to you guys about real
estate agents I trust you guys know that
buying or selling a home is already one
of the most stressful things you can do
and it can be 10 times worse if you're
not working with the right agent usually
our homes are our biggest investment
which is a ton of responsibility and you
need an agent who takes that seriously
which is why I recommend real estate
agents I trust they work with only the
best agents in every Market they do
their homework talking to every agent
before inviting them to join their
Network and here's a big one they only
work with full-time Pros no part-time or
inexperienced agents
their team makes the introduction and
then follows you through the buying or
selling process to make sure that you're
satisfied the agents they work with have
long track records they're the best
sellers in their field and even under
these intense economic conditions with
high interest rates and high inflation
let's go Brandon real estate agents I
trust has provided their customers with
agents who've overcome these challenges
in the past they're part of this
audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
head on over to real estate
agentsitrust.com today and give them
some basic info their team will contact
you to make an introduction to the
preferred agent in your town and
depending on how everything goes today
you can figure out where you want to
live okay so let's focus on the positive
all sorts of things have shifted there
clearly has been a mass red pilling in
the United States a whole bunch of
people who I often describe as liberals
who were just mugged by reality people
who didn't think about government that
much didn't really care about takes that
much or maybe we're marginal Democrats
and thought that the machine kind of
worked right it kind of worked for the
people who suddenly after these two
crazy crazy years that none of us could
have made up this lunacy firing doctors
over not wanting to get an experimental
vaccine I mean the list goes on and on
of all the craziness a whole bunch of
people have woken up one of those people
is Tulsi gabbard now Tulsi gabbard as
you guys know she ran as a Democrat as a
liberal in the last election only two
years ago she was the last Democrat
standing besides Joe Biden and then the
party basically expunged her and only
finally what about a month ago Tulsi
officially announced that she was
leaving the Democrat Party I often say
you don't have to be a republican but
you cannot be a Democrat Tulsi has not
announced that she is a republican but
she's at least taken my lead on this one
here's a video of Tulsi explaining that
explaining why she a liberal is
endorsing someone like Tudor Dixon a
republican in Michigan who of course is
running against Gretchen Whitmer how did
you choose Tudor as someone you were
going to campaign with
um
really for a lot of the reasons
across the country are cowering in fear
of these these radical woke ID logs who
are in control of the party when you put
Tudor Dixon up against Gretchen Whitmer
there's no comparison when
the Right leader for the right time in
this state when you listen to what Tudor
Dixon is talking to people about what
she's hearing from people it doesn't get
any more real than fighting for your
kids fighting for your jobs fighting for
our economy fighting for Safety and
Security it does not get any more real
than that which again just shows how to
touch Barack Obama is and uh and frankly
Gretchen Whitmer as well
truth truth and when you're saying the
truth it ain't hard to talk right you
can kind of be clear and decent and you
can always hear that Clarity and decency
when tulsi's talking now I personally
have differences with Tulsi I think
Tulsi still probably is a little more
open on the abortion issue than I am I
have my limits I'm not exactly sure
where hers are I'd still love to talk to
her about some Second Amendment stuff
she is a supporter of the Second
Amendment anyway none of that really
matters what was it all boiling down to
there for a liberal like Tulsi what it
was boiling down to was that the
Democrat Party has gotten out of control
the woke have taken over the old
vestiges let's say the the Obamas the
clintons it's hard to know what they are
anymore whether Biden is in charge all
of those things so she as a liberal is
now saying hey if I want to defend my
liberal values something that I've
talked about for a long time even in the
book about it if I want to defend those
liberal values I have to do it by
endorsing Republicans this time around
right you have to if you believe America
is fundament fundamentally good if you
believe that the government should get
out of your way if you don't believe in
Endless taxation if you believe in Law
and Order all the stuff guys Tulsi is is
doing it she is acknowledging that the
goal posts have shifted to the point
where somebody like Tudor Dixon has to
run for governor if you did not see it
we posted an interview that I did with
Tudor Dixon over the weekend it has
something like 400 000 views already I
mean people are paying attention to this
stuff Tudor Dixon she's a businesswoman
a mother of four daughters not someone
who is planning on running for governor
but then reality smacked her in the face
Gretchen Whitmer locking everybody down
keeping the kids out of school making
sure that people couldn't plant uh
fruits and vegetables in their Gardens
literally and then Tudor said hey I'm
getting in and now Tulsi is joining her
on that ride and what I really believe
is that this blueprint that we're seeing
this was created right here in this
great state of Florida Ron DeSantis
created the new American blueprint and
that new American blueprint by the way
it's not that different than the old
American blueprint that old American
blueprint that Ronald Reagan was talking
about in the cold open that we showed
you just a moment ago so now what I want
to do for the course of the rest of the
show is I'm going to continue with this
theme of good people figuring it out and
good ideas that should be the things
that we're all voting for today
obviously we're gonna
do a bunch more on what's going on right
here in Florida but we we will go
throughout the country I promise you
that let me talk about raycon earbuds
real quick and then we'll get to it have
you guys started shopping for the
holidays yet no literally why not you
know most gifts don't go bad right the
only thing that'll go bad between now
and December are the crowds at the mall
12 children screaming 11 minutes to find
parking 10 Karen's carrying the list
goes on right now you can shop early
skip the stress and snag some of the
best deals of the season on something
you'll love premium audio products from
raycon their wireless earbuds headphones
and speakers offer premium sound useful
features and almost custom comfortable
fit and up to 54 hours of battery life
and as the person gifting them you've
got to love that they started F the
price of other premium audio brands or
knock that list out all at once and get
30 off by shopping raycon's holiday
bundles right now go to buy raycon.com
Reuben and use code early BF to get 20
off-site wide that's 20 off any raycon
product which happens pretty much never
or save even bigger and get thirty
percent off raycons exclusive holiday
bundles that's code early BF at
byracon.com Reuben for twenty percent
off your raycon purchases by raycon.com
Reuben so what is the blueprint of
freedom the blueprint of freedom is
mostly hey you make decisions for
yourself the government doesn't have to
do that much it can protect the borders
make sure that there isn't Chaos on the
streets but that's about it and guess
what that's exactly what we're doing
here in Florida so let's rewind and see
a little bit about how see a little bit
uh sort of how that blueprint was
written right here in Florida over these
last couple years uh here is Governor
DeSantis saying no to mandates lockdowns
and school closures
did you not get the cdc's memo I don't
see you guys complying
and I say that jokingly but I I think
that that may be a sign of potentially
seeking to do more things into the
future and I think it's very important
that we say unequivocally no two
lockdowns no to school closures no two
restrictions and no mandates
you got to remember guys everyone's sort
of saying this stuff now and there's a
whole bunch of Democrats pretending they
didn't do the stuff that we know that
they did right Gretchen Whitmer in that
debate we showed it to you a couple
times saying that kids were only out of
school for three months even though it
was closer to a year and a half these
bold-faced lies which only Democrats can
do because of democrat privilege the one
privilege which exists in the United
States that you can be a Democrat and
big Tech and the media will always cover
for your lies and then you can destroy
cities Gavin Newsom mayor of San
Francisco destroys San Francisco moves
up to become governor of California that
is Democrat privilege uh it's you can
watch those videos of DeSantis now and
you can go boy sure okay we stayed
stayed open and don't mandate but it's
like when you're doing that when it's
not the popular thing to do it ain't
easy but a little bravery goes a long
way and you know what also goes a long
way how about making sure that the
people keep a bit more of their money
that it isn't just about the endless
sucking sound of the government taking
more of your money to then give it back
to you well that's another thing we're
doing right here in Florida and one of
the ways families have felt the pinch
has been in significantly higher gas
prices to help alleviate this burn for
Florida families I'm proposing a one
billion dollar gas tax holiday to help
reduce prices at the pump if Washington
D.C won't change course then we have a
responsibility to step up on behalf of
our Floridians boy it's really bizarre
you know Florida here we have no state
income tax so that means that every
Floridian keeps more of their money than
anyone that lives in say California or
New York where you're taxed to the high
hell and yet I go out and about here and
we still have roads we still have cops
we still have teachers and then we
proactively when the economy is hurting
because of the bad policies of the
Democrats and Brandon over there we
proactively give tax breaks on things
like gas and he gave tax breaks on
things like uh child products uh this is
what this Governor is doing so that it's
a little bit easier for people to live
their lives as the federal government
constantly encroaches and takes more of
your money and destroys your 401ks and
everything else but you know what also
is good it's also good not to brainwash
a generation of children with the wrong
ideas you wouldn't want to say teach a
bunch of children that they should judge
themselves and others but based on the
color of their skin that was something
that we all knew say five years ago but
we allowed the woke to get in here and
we allowed words like Equity instead of
equality to become part of the the
mainstream thought mainstream group
think and uh it was wrong it was wrong
you also wouldn't want kids let's say a
five-year-old boy thinking that he was a
five-year-old girl or a six-year-old
girl thinking that she was a
five-year-old boy or any which way you
want to do this whole thing and you
certainly wouldn't want state employees
talking to Children about sex and gender
and sexuality and hiding it from the
parents calling children a different
name at school and not telling the
parents about it but that was happening
all over the country and then Ron
DeSantis said no right here in Florida
and he specifically said no to Disney
who was leading the charge on this stuff
from a cultural perspective but I think
Disney took it one step further when
they put out this incredible state
statement after they already did all
their virtue signaling after we signed
the bill saying this was somehow a
violation of Human Rights and that they
would work to see that parents rights
and education were repealed through the
legislature and I'm just thinking to
myself
um you know I took an oath to support
the laws and Constitution of the U.S and
the State of Florida I did not take an
oath to subcontract out my leadership to
a corporation based in Burbank
California they don't run this state
just as a reminder that was the last
show we did on the don't burn this
country tour we did that in Orlando we
were right there in the home of Disney
and I will tell you that during the the
audience meet and greet after the show
where people the VIPs come up and I
usually shake hands take pictures about
100 200 people I met probably a dozen
Disney employees some of them actually
gay even who did not want any of this
nonsense either in Disney itself or in
our schools and everywhere else so you
stand up and you do the right thing it's
not easy to fight
Disney right it's not easy to fight a
billion multi-billion dollar corporation
that has that especially in this state
has so much power in Florida right
because of the amount of jobs and
everything else but he did it and the
polls show and the results tonight will
show that he did the right thing but why
did he do the right thing he did the
right thing because not because he was
just looking to pick a fight to have his
name in the paper right it wasn't that
it was what he said there that his oath
of office
was to the Constitution of the United
States and to the state and the people
of Florida and when you do the right
thing we we don't we don't make it known
enough that if you do the right thing
that you will be rewarded for it but you
do get rewarded for it because then more
people start doing it and it gets a
little bit easier on you and that is
something that DeSantis has done and I
suspect he will continue to do for all
the right reasons my job is to protect
the education opportunities and the jobs
of the people of my state and if doing
so means I put my own job in Jeopardy
we'll let the chips fall where they may
leadership is about standing up for
other people before you worry about your
own hide
yeah well you know let the chips fall
where they may I think they're going to
fall uh in a pretty Red Basket this
evening here in Florida we shall see but
okay I don't want to just focus on
Florida I know that not all of you live
in Florida you live all over the country
and all over the world obviously I focus
on Florida because this is the blueprint
like this is the blueprint that you got
to take to your state to your city to
your local municipality this these are
the type of people that you want to
replicate the ideas that you want to
take within you and then export right
like that's the whole point of all this
but there are plenty of other candidates
who I think sort of appeared out of
nowhere let's not forget a couple of
years ago Ron DeSantis was a little
known congressman who only won by 30 000
votes over a guy that turned out to be
an orgy going meth addict you know all
right nobody's perfect but that's what
we could have had here in Florida and
and then instead he stepped into it and
then once he stepped into it he really
exploded because of it and I think that
that showed a couple of other people
that you should get involved and and I'm
fortunate to say that I've been able to
interview and get to know a lot of these
people and I think there's going to be
some good results tonight just a
reminder guys that since election night
is tonight and the stakes have never
been higher The Blaze wants to help you
guys make sense of everything as you
know it's possible that the Republicans
are going to win a senate seat in
Washington state Lee zeldin might knock
off Kathy hochel this evening I suspect
Tudor Dixon is going to take down
Gretchen Whitmer after all the covert
lockdown insanity and if you want all
the info that you need for this evening
you can head on over right now to
theblaze.com election guide to receive a
free copy of Blaze media's Ultimate
Guide to the midterms delivered right to
your in inbox that's theblaze.com
election guide and they'll send you
everything you need to know to be ready
for election night tonight and by the
way when I am at the DeSantis HQ tonight
and the Victory party and all that and
as I said we'll figure out what time
time we're gonna live stream because it
depends on sort of how the results are
coming in and what's going on over there
and it's going to be a little bit of
chaos I think I'm jumping on stage a
couple times and all that I also will be
Skyping in to the blaze coverage this
evening with Glenn Beck and everybody
over there I think Michael malice will
be joining the guys in Dallas tonight
and all that good stuff so okay so what
else is going on well
a lot of people as I talked about
yesterday that you would not think of as
politicians people from the media people
from the tech world uh people that were
not traditional DC uh creatures they
started appearing in politics I was one
of the first people to interview Blake
Masters I think it was July of 2021 when
basically nobody knew him there were a
whole bunch of other Republicans running
and it didn't it I mean most people did
not think that this guy was going to do
anything well it looks like by the end
of tonight he might just be the next
senator from Arizona uh here is a Blake
Masters portion of a Blake Masters
campaign ad that I thought just just was
just right just right
Rising prices mean that we all have to
take a second look at our shopping lists
set priorities so let's look at Mark
Kelly's how about hiring 18 000 new
border patrol agents does that sound
good
well Mark Kelly voted no what are you
doing said he voted for 87 000 new IRS
agents Mark Kelly kept our border wide
open but he's sending Tax Collectors
coming after you
I'm Blake Masters I'm dive from this
message
thank you
Blake is a good dude I've gotten to know
him quite well he's a good dude and the
message there like pick one we're going
to do something with agents you want
border agents in a place like Arizona to
protect the Border make sure that
illegals aren't rampaging across the
border and committing crime and all of
that stuff or do you want IRS agents do
you want 87 000 new IRS agents some of
whom are armed to look into more
Americans to find out where they can
squeeze more money at a u the message is
pretty freaking simple and we saw a poll
this morning that for the first time
timing is everything for the first time
Blake Masters is actually leading in the
polls as of this morning so we shall see
what happens in Arizona and speaking of
Arizona I was also one of the first
people to have Carrie Lake on Carrie
Lake former media member former Democrat
former Obama voter got red pill and this
woman some people swallow the red pill
this woman snorted the red pill and you
may remember this one when a CNN
reporter wanted to ask her a couple
questions
you don't have a mask on anymore
that's what we're six feet apart
a minute to chat
um I'll do an interview okay as long as
it airs on CNN Plus
does still exist I didn't think so
because the people don't like what you
guys are peddling which is propaganda
thank you
started I mean like how much better do
you want it like that was just silent
but deadly just think you don't even
know it's like 20 minutes later you
already swallowed the poison nothing you
could do now lady just absolutely
perfect and she has what I think Carrie
lake has done perhaps better than anyone
else in this election cycle is map out
how do you fight you guys are propaganda
propaganda enough of this nonsense but
the other way to fight is call out the
Democrats for the bad policies so let's
say you lived in a place like New York
and in New York during most of covid
they had a guy by the name of Andrew
Cuomo and then Andrew Cuomo who of
course everyone was saying was going to
be the next president of the United
States and maybe Biden was going to make
him attorney general and he wrote a book
during covid about leadership which of
course he got what did he get like a two
three million dollar advance on that
book uh then it turned out he killed all
these people in the old age homes and
you know the story on all that uh then
he gets replaced by Kathy hochel Kathy
is sort of the worst of the worst I
don't believe she has any real support
in New York I mean I get
that there's a certain amount of Union
support people that are just like they
just vote on one or two issue okay she's
four eight-month abortions we love her
but people have had it in New York
they've had it with the disastrous
economic conditions they've had it with
what she was pushing for and said she
would do again just in the debate a week
or two ago when she was talking about
how she would do lockdowns and mask
mandates and all that stuff she said she
would do it all over she would do it all
over but more than anything else what's
the real issue in New York the real
issue in New York is crime and everyone
gets it New York City is not safe
anymore but it's been exported into the
suburbs and Lee zeldin little-known
Congressman nobody really knew of the
guy two months ago he has come out of
nowhere massive freaking rallies massive
rallies he's leading in some of the
polls right now New York Post this
morning basically saying let's make this
happen like it could be here and even in
crazy blue New York they've had
Republican governors in the past George
Pataki not too long ago they've had
crazy right wing Republican Mayors in
New York Rudy Giuliani right not too
long ago it can happen and if you are
watching from New York I wish you an
awful lot of luck uh but what do you
have to do you got to call these people
out directly here's Lee's Eldon this
this governor who still to this moment
we're not what are we halfway through
the debate she still hasn't talked about
locking up anyone committing any crimes
okay anyone who commits a crime under
our laws especially with the change they
made to bail has consequences I don't
know why that's so important you
I don't know why that's so important to
you like that moment why is crime so
important to you you know it's like
Kathy you walk around with armed
security wherever you go you don't go on
the subway okay she did go on Subway for
a photo op a couple days ago in Brooklyn
but she obviously had armed security
just out of the lens of the camera right
we all know it people have caught on to
the nonsense man imagine if New York
like that's the one tonight that's the
one if New York turned what what a
signal that would be for the rest of the
country but another one I would say a
close second is what's going on in
Michigan right people don't really pay
that much attention to Michigan but
Gretchen Whitmer became sort of a Disney
villain in the midst of covid with the
insanity of the lockdowns and she's
going on private boats while she's
telling other people they can or
husband's birthday party and going to
fancy dinners and all of this just
everything she did it was just awful and
so dismissive of freedom and decent
people and then you know what happened a
decent person got involved in the
election her name is Tudor Dixon here's
a portion of her last dad
[Music]
on November 8th we will go to the polls
and vote to restore education in this
state to make sure there is no wrong
path for any child in the state of
Michigan to make sure that we bring back
safe communities and support our law
enforcement officers and to build the
American dream in the state of Michigan
once again
that scary right-wing stuff is that mean
Republican stuff and we only care about
war and money or is that hey how about
we care about Freedom how about we care
about making sure you have a job and
we're not going to abuse your kids how
about that that's really what the
Republicans are offering right now again
as I keep saying it's like if all of
these people come together the ex-libs
and the Libertarians and the
conservatives and The Independents of
whatever if we just get through the woke
thing and we have this Red Wave we can
hash out all our differences and that'll
be fun after to really have that battle
of ideas and that's what America used to
always be about because the fundamental
stuff was there right rule of law that
this place is good the experiment is
worth continuing so we can get to the
other side but we can only get to the
other side if we start electing these
types of people another one of these
people is JD Vance in Ohio a guy that
again nobody knew was not getting into
politics has a successful career does
some some VC stuff like did not have to
do this but had just had about enough
with the Border had just had enough uh
had about enough with the fentanyl
situation and uh and then he got in and
he's running against Democrat Tim Ryan
the choice for Ohio voters is so clear
you have a guy who's been very
anti-police very Pro
um very very pro-inflationary policies
and you have an alternative and I'm the
alternative and I think people are not
feeling like the state's going the right
direction right now like the country's
going the right direction so I think
that puts us in a good position in
November it's good to be up in the polls
but at the end of the day we just have
to run our race get our message out and
I think we'll be in good shape recent
polls show this is a tight race with JD
Vance up three points in a recent
Emerson College poll my argument is
pretty simple uh the Tim Ryan that I'm
worried about is not the Tim Ryan of his
well-produced TV commercials it's the
Tim Ryan who's been in Washington for 20
years who always votes with Pelosi and
Biden and never takes an independent
vote never takes an independent stance
when the people of Ohio really need him
to now what you guys know this I mean
what does the machine do when they see
someone gaining momentum well they
always they will try to to pin them into
their they're an ultra Maga right-wing
white nationalist Christian extremist
something something something
JD Vance did not even support Donald
Trump four years ago he happened to have
been on stage in Ohio uh was it
yesterday with Donald Trump but the idea
that this is some like traditional
far-right mean conservative is just
complete nonsense and that's a perfect
segue to what's going on in Pennsylvania
because Dr Oz Mehmet Oz who if you would
have asked anyone seven years ago
everyone basically liked Hollywood liked
him Oprah put him on the map right he
was the doctor that would go on Oprah's
show and so many people loved the guy
Democrats I mean the the Middle America
housewives that watch over they loved oz
so much that they spun him off into his
own daily syndicated show by no
estimation is this guy an extremist or
any of the things that they can
traditionally say about Republicans
anything like that but he is running as
a Republican and as I keep saying about
Oz I have a lot of hope for us because I
feel like he's sort of cut from my cloth
that he probably basically was just a
moderate Democrat then saw the lunacy
and then because of that you can in some
ways become the clearest and most
concise and most consistent what I would
say is sort of a new new school
conservative so here's Dr Oz comparing
himself with
lieutenant governor of Pennsylvania John
Federman after medical school in
Philadelphia people put their lives in
my hands patients trusted me to do my
job and fight for them that's not how
Washington Works we're facing Rising
crime crushing inflation lives
unraveling radical John Federman spent a
career in politics making things worse
he'd hurt us I'll heal us and bring
change to our divided nation doctors fix
big things I fixed hearts and fought for
every last one Dr Oz I approved this
message okay I get it ads or ads
and Will some of these people disappoint
you along the way of course they will
but it's such an obvious Stark choice in
Pennsylvania I I would say if once if
I'm most worried about one state I would
say it's Pennsylvania because the
Machinery there remember pipe burst in
2020 in the middle of the night like
there was some weird stuff in
Pennsylvania Philadelphia specifically
uh but we shall see but if it is not
obvious to the average person in
Pennsylvania like is Oz he's basically a
moderate he's basically a moderate
versus really a socialist who wants to
put criminals on the street who wants to
do nothing about crime who's in all in
on it with everything that Biden and the
Democrats are doing on top of the fact
that he has trouble communicating he had
this stroke which has been quite
debilitating and that's an issue it's
just an issue it's just reality I know
they don't like to see reality because
then they'd have to also you know tell
you that Biden's got an issue too but
let's just put that aside for now what
else is going on on well there's a
senate race in Georgia and Herschel
Walker is going against Rafael Warnock
Rafael Warnock who is also a preacher
who often preaches about how evil
whiteness is and a whole bunch of other
racist stuff so then Herschel Walker who
was a huge NFL superstar former now
retired athlete I don't think this was a
guy that was planning to get into
politics well now he jumped in as well
[Music]
right now you can see what they're doing
they'll do whatever it takes but say
whatever they have to say because they
want this seat right here
but I don't think they know that they
woke up
have you seen the crime in the streets
hey have you seen that border wide open
the gas prices Walton isn't all military
and what is Senator one not doing is
absolutely not
but two years he's been in office
and can you take six more of this here
you can't take six more of this this
time of us get Champions there that's
going to get behind our military it's
time for us to get Champions there
they're going to get behind our kids in
school that they can quit calling our
parents domestic terrorists so I said
what we gotta do let's get out in
November and vote this is the greatest
country in the world today
and the reason why is that people
isn't it interesting because everyone
that I've shown you here displays some
element of something refreshing it's
something refreshing and also something
kind of old like that's the irony right
it's refreshing it feels new but it's
something that we used to just have like
a pride in America and we'd like a
strong military not something we have to
go to war endlessly but so that we can
protect ourselves and maintain our
stature in the world uh maintaining some
ability for you to parent your child as
you see fit and so much of this as I
said at the top has been modeled off of
what Ron DeSantis has done right here in
Florida so the DeSantis campaign
yesterday put out their final ad and I
think what they did here was really
really clever what would this have all
been like if Florida had gone in a
different direction
what if things had gone differently
our experts have just made the call
Democrats have won the State of Florida
what if people's jobs were lost not
saved what if students couldn't learn
because no one stood up for them what if
you called for help but no one answered
only a few thousand votes made the
difference four years ago between a
state living in fear and a state
Fighting For Freedom this November let's
show the world that freedom is here to
stay
that's the point guys that that is the
point it does not matter if you live in
New York or you live in Florida or you
live in Montana Pennsylvania Arizona or
anywhere else freedom is on the ballot
look how close we got to the edge we got
right there looked and looked at that
abyss and what was in that Abyss that
Abyss was lockdowns it was mandates it
was endless government control endless
demonization of the other citizen who
did not want to do what you might want
them to do we got pretty damn close and
it was fueled by algorithms and it was
fueled by an Ever encroaching government
and the Democrats did not have to do
this but they made their choice so we
have to make our choice today and our
choice should be to stop them and then
we'll deal with our differences because
America has something so beautiful that
is the jealousy of the world really
think about it think about your family
for just one second think about whether
it was your parents that came here or
whether you're first generation or
whether it was your great grandparents
or whether your great great great great
grandparents were Founders think about
your family why did they come here they
came here for the opportunity for
Freedom everyone comes here because it's
still better here than pretty much
anywhere else it's why AOC does not
leave it's why ilhan Omar does not leave
and yet they have decided with the Biden
Administration to import all the ideas
that our ancestors fled from
we can stop it today we truly can do you
remember
the America that I'm talking about I
think you should you probably do even
though they make it very hard to
remember but it was good it was good and
decent and just and uh well Ronald
Reagan do a little something about that
let our friends
and those who may wish us ill take note
the United States has an obligation to
its citizens and to the people of the
world never to let those who would
destroy freedom dictate the future
course of Life on this planet
[Applause]
yes how about that
all right guys we got a close-up shop a
little bit early today because we got to
get on the road to Tampa so that we make
sure we're in time for the big DeSantis
Victory party this evening but as I said
we will be live streaming uh from
DeSantis HQ tonight and I'll be
co-hosting some of the blaze coverage as
we see fit I'll be Skyping in and out
throughout the evening we got a cold
close for you in just a moment let me
get to a couple locals comments and then
we're out of here uh Tony says do you
think elections would be more fair if
candidate parties weren't listed on the
ballot you know that's interesting and I
I did think about that for a moment
today because as I was filling out the
ballot there are two or three things
even for someone that's as informed as I
am and I know what propositions are on
there and I was really prepared there
were one or two things with a judge and
something else that I wasn't totally
sure and then you know they put uh
Republican Democrat independent
libertarian they put that on there I
suppose you could remove some of that
but I think since most people
unfortunately go in mostly unarmed with
the information they should have if you
basically like at this point if you were
basically like hey I'm kind of into
Freedom then you pretty much have to
vote Republicans so it probably guides
people a little bit I think you could
probably argue it either way Brad says
what craziness do you think the unhinged
left will attempt to pull between
election day and January when they know
their power is slipping from them well
first off let's get through tonight
let's just get through tonight you know
there were a couple articles we showed
you one of them
yesterday mainstream media suddenly we
won't be able to make election results
uh available this evening it should take
a few days we need to be able to count
mail-in ballots oh and I do want to say
something because Phoenix and I were
discussing it this morning about the
mail-in ballot thing now now Florida has
unbelievably secure elections here and I
had to show my ID it was wild I had to
actually show my ID it was just very
clear that the chain of command between
me and it wasn't on a digital screen I
had to actually use a pen and paper it
then had then it was put in an envelope
I then walked it myself to the box that
you put it in a guy made sure that I did
it properly like it was clear the chain
of command all the Clean and Clear and
crisp right
um but many places don't have IDs right
so you don't have to have an ID to vote
it is completely insane but on the
mail-in ballot thing itself now first
off the Democrats went bananas on Mel
and ballots during covet right so that
was their thing you know you don't want
Grandma to get sick you don't want to
get sick so mail-in ballots as I said
when I was in California doing the mail
and ballot thing when I voted it was a
year basically a year ago right now for
the recall I did it in person but I did
have the mail-in ballot because they
send it to everybody regardless and no
matter which way you folded your ballot
you could see through the envelope and
see that you voted for Larry Elder we
tried it we tried it you could see it no
matter which way okay but if you really
believe that mail-in ballots were
important and it was only about making
sure everybody could vote and it was a
vital part of the process wouldn't you
make sure that the mail-in ballot has to
be in let's say postmarked and in and
recovered received by say two days
before the election so that they would
have that number
on Election Day and then they would just
be adding the day of uh votes to it that
would be the most same thing but the way
they are trying to do this now and this
is a this is a construct of the media
and the Democrat Party is that no no no
no no it sure it's going to look like
the Republicans are winning throughout
the evening but then guys around 10 p.m
you have to remember we're waiting for
all of those other ballots to come in so
we'll let you know in a couple days it's
like their lies are right in our face if
you wanted to do it honestly there are
ways to do it honestly uh Elizabeth says
everyone is tired of career politicians
that just work for their own gains we
want people who will work for the good
of America yeah and it's like who really
seems like they're the good person in
these in these elections right now is it
Kathy hochel does she seem like she
really cares about people that she's
literally saying she would do it all
again or at least Elden who got attacked
on stage by the way you may remember
that about a month and a half ago
who's trying to fight back against the
crime in New York who seems like the
good person that's in touch with the
people is it Gretchen Whitmer who did
all of the lockdown stuff while partying
privately or is it Tudor Dixon the mom
of four who got dragged into this the
list goes on and on you guys you guys
get it uh reminder guys live streaming
tonight rumble.com Ruben report uh
youtube.com reubenreport and of course
on
reubenport.locals.com a part one of my
interview with Michael Shermer is up
right now we're going to cold close you
with the DeSantis ad and as I said I
will be live from DeSantis HQ in Tampa
this evening so stay tuned for more info
on that get out and vote guys it's an
exciting day pray for America right pray
for America
um and uh let's see what happens like I
think I think tonight's going to be good
you never know
um but let's let's go to Tampa and party
tonight all right see you later
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
aren't you glad to live in the Free
State of Florida
we are going to carry this torch of
Freedom onward because our mission is
very simple we are keeping the State of
Florida free thank you all God bless you
foreign